.
* Langgezogene Akkordeonklänge *
* Einsetzender Jodel *
Seit 15 Jahren
ist Heinz Gerig in schwieriger
Mission im Land unterwegs.
Sein Bestreben:
arbeitslose Flüchtlinge
in die hiesige Arbeitswelt, in
die Schweizer Gesellschaft zu führen.
Oft scheinen die kulturellen
Differenzen unüberbrückbar.
Doch der Mann ist hartnäckig:
Gerig, ein Pionier in der Integration
fremder Menschen, fordert viel,
doch ebenso fördert er auch.
* Langatmiger, hoher Jodel *
Wenn wir jetzt nichts daraus machen,
holt uns das irgendwann ein.
Denn diese Probleme werden wachsen.
Wenn wir diese Menschen
so weit bringen können,
dass wir sie zu einem Teil
unserer Wirtschaft machen können,
dann haben alle profitiert.
Im Jahr 2015 ist Heinz Gerig
im luzernischen Emmenbrücke tätig.
Niemand, niemand in der Schweiz
hat auf Sie gewartet. Niemand!
Schonungslos begrüsst Gerig
die 15 Kursteilnehmer
zu dieser Gastroausbildung.
... müssen Sie sich gut merken.
Zu diesem Integrationskurs
für Flüchtlinge.
Die Realität ist hart,
kalt und brutal.
Die muss ich ihnen beibringen.
Es nützt einfach nichts,
wenn ich ihnen sage:
"Versucht es mal,
das kommt dann schon irgendwie."
Das geht nicht, sondern: "Du hast
keine andere Wahl, du musst!"
Mit der Nagelfeile schön feilen.
Die Damen sowieso.
Das sieht gut aus,
schon viel, viel besser.
Noch etwas daran arbeiten,
überall gleich kurz.
Oh, herrlich!
Es ist der fünfwöchige Servicekurs,
eine wahre Herausforderung
für die Flüchtlinge,
nicht nur was das richtige Platzieren
der Fliege anbelangt.
Einmal habe ich im RIESCO-Kurs
Essen mitgebracht,
und ich habe
mit den Händen gegessen.
Das ist nicht Schweizer Kultur.
Frau Doris Wobmann hat mir gesagt:
"Bitte,
wir sind nicht in Afghanistan."
"Du musst immer mit Besteck essen."
Und, ähm ...
"Einen Teller
und eine Serviette bringen,
danach kannst du gut essen."
Was könnte für Sie
ein Problem in diesem Kurs sein?
Ich glaube ...
Ich glaube ... ähm ...
Es fehlt ...
... pünktlich.
Die Pünktlichkeit?
Ich bin sicher, Sie werden sich
daran gewöhnen, wenn Sie es wollen.
Oh mein Gott.
Die Pünktlichkeit in der Schweiz
ist eine fundamentale Sache.
Ich musste mich also ändern.
So wurde ich von einem,
der zu spät kommt, zu einem,
der rechtzeitig kommt.
Und ich bin froh darüber.
Sie haben das Gefühl, Sie können
kommen und gehen, wann Sie wollen.
Ich hatte so viele Anrufe:
"Er ist nicht gekommen."
"Er nimmt den Anruf nicht entgegen,
er meldet sich nicht ab."
So geht das nicht.
Wir waren mit dieser Kultur
nicht vertraut,
dass man das Richtige
zur richtigen Zeit machen muss,
dass man pünktlich sein muss,
dass man keine Lektion
verpassen darf,
dass man im Küchenpraktikum
nicht fehlen darf.
* Langgezogene Geigenklänge *
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
Emmenbrücke bei Luzern, Februar 2015.
Isa Villayaty.
Selvalratnam Melayupitapilay.
Herr Haptong.
Herr Fesea Tesfay.
Herr Bereket Tesfay.
Gut, dann legen wir los.
Ich erkläre Ihnen, worum es geht.
Heinz Gerig
ist ein Freund klarer Worte.
Und mit solchen
begrüsst er die Interessenten
für einen einjährigen
Integrationskurs.
RIESCO heisst dieser
und soll arbeitslosen Flüchtlingen
endlich den beruflichen Einstieg
ermöglichen.
In der Schweiz sind
60 % der Flüchtlinge ohne Arbeit,
leben von der Sozialhilfe,
und das oft jahrelang.
Heinz Gerigs Einblick
ins Kursprogramm
klingt nicht eben verlockend,
eher abschreckend.
Sie werden
sehr viele Schweisstropfen haben.
Sie werden manchmal fluchen.
Sie werden manchmal
böse sein mit mir.
Das weiss ich jetzt schon.
Aber das Ziel, das ist klar:
der Abschluss dieses Kurses -
das bringt Sie weiter.
Werte und Normen. Ich habe hier
typische Schweizer Normen.
Also, z.B. die Pünktlichkeit
in der Schweiz.
Das ist eine Norm.
Das steht nirgends geschrieben,
aber jeder weiss es.
Die Schweizer werden böse,
wenn die Menschen zu spät kommen.
Und genau hier
lernen Sie solche Dinge.
Jedes Mal, wenn Sie etwas erleben
und Sie merken,
dass der Schweizer böse wird,
dann ist irgendwo hier etwas schief-
gegangen oder Sie wissen es nicht.
Ich kann Ihnen 100 % garantieren:
Diejenigen, die den Kurs
hier beginnen werden,
die werden nach einem Jahr
eine komplett andere Person sein.
100 %!
Nun wird selektioniert.
Denn es sollen nur die Besten
einen Platz erhalten.
Mike Kuhn, der Ko-Leiter,
verteilt einen Deutschtest.
Noch einmal, der erste Satz:
Sie möchten in die Berge nach
Zermatt fahren. Kennen Sie Zermatt?
Zermatt ist ein Ort -
wie Emmenbrücke oder wie Luzern.
Zermatt ist ein Ort.
Jetzt müssen Sie eine kurze E-Mail
an die dortige Touristeninformation
schreiben.
Sie müssen fragen, wie viel
die Hotels in Zermatt kosten.
Ein Hotelzimmer in Zermatt -
wie unwirklich schön
muss das klingen für jene,
die auf ihrer langen Reise
in einem Boot auf dem Mittelmeer
oder in den Strassen Italiens
nächtigen mussten.
RIESCO ist ein Pionierkurs
für Flüchtlinge,
angeboten von der Branchenorganisa-
tion Hotel & Gastro formation.
Ist das gut?
Wie lange sind Sie
jetzt schon in der Schweiz?
Seit drei Jahren.
- Seit drei Jahren.
Okay.
Warum soll ich Sie nehmen?
Wieso sind Sie besser
als die anderen?
Ich habe schon ein Jahr
in meinem Heimatland gearbeitet.
Mhm.
Sie haben also Erfahrung.
Jawohl.
- Ja.
Was noch?
- Ich möchte arbeiten.
D.h., Sie sind motiviert.
- Ja.
Sie wollen.
Wie lange sind Sie bereits in der
Schweiz? Wie lange sind Sie hier?
In der Schweiz? - Ja.
- Drei Jahre. - Drei Jahre.
Haben Sie schon einmal in Ihrem
Leben in der Gastronomie gearbeitet?
Nein. - Noch nie?
- Nein. - Okay.
Eine Schürze.
Der Kurs, gelegentlich
auch Flüchtlingslehre genannt,
findet in der Kantine
der einstigen Textilfabrik Viscose
in Emmenbrücke statt.
Dieses Torchon braucht man nur,
wenn etwas heiss ist,
wenn Sie z.B.
hier die Pfanne nehmen.
So, dazu.
Erste Schritte
in einer Schweizer Küche.
Schritte, welche diese Flüchtlinge
in die Selbständigkeit führen sollen,
denn bislang waren diese Menschen
bei der Arbeitssuche erfolglos.
V.a. jene Leute, die ...
... seit eins, zwei, drei Jahren
ohne Arbeit sind,
die nicht aus dem Haus kommen,
nirgends unterkommen.
Bei ihnen wird
der persönliche Druck so gross.
Da stellt sich die Überlegung,
und sie merken es auch:
"Ich muss etwas verändern."
Sie haben es heute
eigentlich alle gesagt.
Die einzige Chance,
sich vom Sozialamt zu lösen
überhaupt in den Markt zu kommen -
ist eine Ausbildung.
Das ist die einzige Chance.
Und noch immer versuchen Heinz Gerig
und Mike Kuhn herauszufinden,
wer am besten in den Kurs passt.
Warum in die Schweiz?
Warum nicht Deutschland
oder Italien?
Warum sind Sie
in die Schweiz gekommen?
(In gebrochenem Deutsch)
Die Schweiz ist ...
Die Schweiz ist ein bekanntes Land
für human rights.
Mhm, für die Menschenrechte, ja.
Wieso soll ich jetzt Sie nehmen?
Sie müssen besser sein als er,
sonst nehme ich ihn.
(In gebrochenem Deutsch) Weil ich
gesund bin, weil ich aktiv bin
und weil ich freundlich bin.
- Mhm.
Ich bin immer
rechtzeitig zur Arbeit gekommen.
Ja.
Tsering Lhalong,
tibetischer Flüchtling,
2015 mit der Schweizer Arbeitswelt
in Kontakt gekommen.
Vier Jahre später.
Das Paraplegiker-Zentrum Nottwil
am Sempachersee.
1'000 Mahlzeiten
werden hier täglich verlangt.
Und all das gebrauchte Geschirr
kommt zu Tsering Lhalong.
2015 hat er erfolgreich
den RIESCO-Kurs beendet.
Und seither arbeitet er,
der einstige tibetische Bauer,
in der Geschirrreinigung
des Paraplegiker-Zentrums.
Ich habe hier eine Stelle gefunden.
Mit der Arbeit ist alles gut.
Ich komme jeden Tag gerne hierher,
ich arbeite auch sehr gut.
Aber ich will weiterkommen ...
Für meine Zukunft muss ich
noch etwas anderes lernen.
Was möchtest du lernen?
Ich brauche etwas elotonisches ...
Elektronik.
- Ja.
Warum Elektronik?
- Weil ich es mag.
Vincent Studer ist sein Chef, ein
zufriedener Chef, kann man sagen -
und ein verständnisvoller.
Ich möchte nicht,
dass ein so junger Bursche
bis 65 an der Abwaschmaschine steht.
Wenn er sich Mühe gibt,
helfe ich ihm gerne
zu einer anderen Stelle
oder anderen Ausbildung.
Man merkt,
dass er gerne etwas anderes machen
würde, etwas Anspruchsvolleres.
Das hier ist seine erste Stelle,
die er in der Schweiz hat.
Er muss in Gottes Namen das machen,
was übrig geblieben ist.
Aber es wäre ...
Er hat ganz sicher Potenzial.
Tsering Lhalong lebt alleine
in der Schweiz, seit sieben Jahren.
Seine Frau und das gemeinsame Baby
musste er in Tibet zurücklassen.
Die beiden sind der Antrieb dafür,
dass er zuverlässig jeden Tag
seine Arbeit
an der Geschirrspülmaschine leistet.
Denn er,
der bislang nur einen F-Ausweis hat,
jenen für vorläufig Aufgenommene,
möchte sich bewähren,
sodass er den Ausweis B bekommt.
Dann könnte er Frau und Kind nach-
kommen lassen: sein grösster Wunsch.
Das ist für mich
sehr, sehr schwierig ohne ...
... ohne Kind und Frau.
Die Familie ist zu weit weg.
Ich wohne alleine.
Wenn ich alleine zu Hause bin,
denke ich über die Familie nach,
über mein Kind.
Das ist sehr ... ein bisschen ...
Ja.
Es ist sehr schwierig.
Es ist viel besser geworden,
seit wir das machen. - Ja.
Zu Hause geht es gut? Mit dem Umzug?
- Ja.
Vincent Studer, sein Schweizer Chef,
führt hier eine
sehr internationale Küchenbrigade.
Es hat sich auf dieser Welt
auch sehr viel verändert,
wovon wir auch lange profitierten.
Ich glaube, wir müssen es
so annehmen, wie es ist,
und etwas daraus machen.
Sich zu wehren nützt nichts.
Das Problem ...
Also die Leute sind da.
Wir müssen versuchen,
mit ihnen irgendeinen Konsens
zu finden.
Wir müssen mit ihnen leben.
Es ist nicht mehr so,
dass wir um die Schweiz herum
eine Grenze ziehen können,
Fahnen schwingen und irgendwo
auf der Welt in die Ferien gehen.
Diese Zeiten sind vorbei.
* Langgezogene Akkordeonklänge,
einsetzendes Summen *
Es ist Aschermittwochmorgen.
Viele Einheimische schlafen
zu dieser Zeit die Fasnacht aus.
Über 40 Flüchtlinge hatten sich für
einen Platz in diesem Kurs beworben.
15 haben es geschafft.
Für diese beginnt heute
die Verwandlung
in eine arbeitsmarktfähige Person.
Kursleiter Heinz Gerig
erklärt unzimperlich,
was das Ziel
dieses Kurses ist.
Sie müssen zehnmal besser sein
als all diese Schweizer,
die hier sind
und keine Stelle haben.
Sie müssen besser sein als die.
Und dann haben Sie eine Chance.
Und das werden Sie auch.
Zu Beginn steht das Fach "Werte
und Normen" auf dem Stundenplan,
womöglich das schwierigste Schulfach
für diese Menschen
aus einer anderen Welt.
Zuerst führt Kursleiterin
Doris Wobmann die Klasse
durch die Schulräumlichkeiten.
Schon bald läuft in der Lingerie
eine kleine Wertedebatte.
Wer von Ihnen kann gut bügeln?
(Mann) Die Frauen.
- Die Frauen?
Ich habe jemanden gesehen,
der gut bügeln kann.
Schauen Sie,
es ist keine Frauenarbeit.
Bügeln können alle.
Wenn ich morgen
oder übermorgen Zeit habe,
werde ich mit den Männern
bügeln trainieren,
nicht mit den Frauen.
- Aber ich bin nicht gut.
Ich bin auch nicht gut.
Die ersten Lektionen befassen sich
mit den grundlegenden Dingen
des Lebens.
Dinge, über die man
nicht so leicht spricht.
Wenn Sie auf die Toilette gehen, ich
bitte Sie, waschen Sie Ihre Hände!
Nach der Toilette.
- Muss. - Das ist ein Muss.
Und bitte stehen Sie nicht
auf die Toilette!
Die Toilette ist nicht zum Drauf-
stehen, sondern zum Draufsitzen.
Und wenn Sie jetzt lächeln -
ich habe das schon gesehen.
(Heinz Gerig) Und darum
ist es auch wirklich ganz wichtig,
mit den Duschen etc.
Die sind zum Duschen da
und nicht, um Pipi zu machen.
Christen, Muslime, Buddhisten
sind hier versammelt.
Doch das soll keine Rolle spielen.
Religion - grundsätzlich
müssen Sie sich gut merken:
Es ist absolut unwichtig,
welche Religion Sie haben.
Das ist absolut unwichtig.
Wichtig ist, dass Sie eine haben.
Die, die Sie haben,
ist die richtige.
Ich weiss auch nicht,
welche die richtige ist.
Heinz Gerig, gelernter Koch
und Erwachsenenbildner,
ein erfahrener Handwerker
der Integration.
Vier Jahre sind
seit jenem RIESCO-Kurs vergangen.
Heinz Gerig bietet
neue Flüchtlingskurse an.
Seine grösste Herausforderung:
Flüchtlinge
als Pflegehelfende auszubilden.
Wir hatten sehr grosse Schwierig-
keiten, am Anfang sprachlich.
Wir mussten
die ganzen Programme umstellen
und die Deutschförderung
verstärkt einbinden.
Es ist so, dass die Deutschförderung
nicht immer sofort greift,
weil es in der Pflege
sehr viele Fremdwörter gibt.
Es war etwas sehr Schwieriges.
Wir sind mit 15 Personen gestartet,
jetzt sind es nur noch neun.
Reise ins Wallis, nach Brig,
wo der Pilotkurs zeigen soll,
ob es schliesslich doch noch klappt.
(Frau) Psychisch kranke Menschen ...
... vielleicht ein bisschen komisch,
schwierig.
Die sind anders.
Was soll ich machen? Was denke ich?
Kennt ihr jemanden,
der schon mal so krank war?
Demenz.
- Das ist eine psychische Krankheit.
Wahnvorstellungen.
Wenn Sie Bilder im Kopf haben,
die nicht existieren,
und Sie dann Angst haben.
Wenn Sie immer Gedanken haben,
die schrecklich sind,
die Ihnen Angst machen.
Das nennt man Wahnvorstellungen.
Aha!
Der einjährige Pflegekurs
wird in Zusammenarbeit
mit dem Roten Kreuz Oberwallis
durchgeführt,
zuständig ist Natalie Zurwerra.
Sie hat Erstaunliches erlebt.
Frau Kunsam hat in Tibet
keine Schule besucht,
sie hatte keine Schulbildung.
Sie ist mit sehr
wenigen Kenntnissen gekommen.
Sie musste die Sprache lernen
und auch lernen zu schreiben.
Sie hat das sehr gut gemeistert.
Sie hat sehr viel gearbeitet,
sehr viele Stunden nebenbei.
Diese Fortschritte -
so etwas habe ich noch nie gesehen.
Heinz Gerig
tröstet eine junge tibetische Frau.
Deren Mutter liegt
in der Heimat im Sterben -
und ihre Tochter
kann nicht bei ihr sein.
Noch stärker als im Gastrobereich
können in der Pflege
kulturelle Unterschiede
zum Stolperstein werden.
Diesbezüglich muss dieser Kurs
einiges leisten.
Allein, dass es überhaupt
Altersheime gibt ...
Wir haben hier Nationen,
z.B. Tibeter,
die können nicht nachvollziehen,
dass es Altersheime gibt.
Das ist für sie
eine absolute Schande.
Das gibt es in ganz Tibet nicht.
Und hier machen wir das.
Das verlangte von ihnen
einen grossen Schritt,
überhaupt in dem Bereich
zu arbeiten,
obwohl es ihrer Mentalität
widerspricht
und auch gegen ihr Herz
und ihr Verhalten ist.
Der Tod und seine Rituale -
ein heikles Thema,
das in einem Pflegekurs
zur Sprache kommen muss.
Die Tibeter
zerstückeln ihre Verstorbenen.
Sie legen sie auf den Berg, wo sie
von den Vögel gefressen werden.
Es war für sie sehr komisch,
für einen Moslem z.B.,
der hat die Welt
nicht mehr verstanden.
(Mann) Sie haben hier Wasserfarben
und verschiedene Pinsel.
Damit können Sie gestalten.
Die männlichen Kursteilnehmer
erhalten heute Ideen vermittelt
für die Beschäftigung von Betagten.
Es sind nur noch wenige Tage
bis zum Kursende.
Von den 15, welche die Ausbildung
begonnen haben, sind noch neun dabei.
Die anderen mussten v.a.
aus sprachlichen Gründen aufgeben.
Und doch, für Natalie Zurwerra
ist der Pilotkurs ein Erfolg,
denn die Rückmeldungen der
Praktikumsbetriebe sind ermutigend.
Wir haben bereits fünf Teilnehmer
mit einer Festanstellung.
Sie waren für die Teams
wirklich sehr wertvoll.
Für mich ist ganz klar,
dass sich der Aufwand
und die Energie gelohnt haben.
Das Pilotprojekt
könnte weiterbestehen.
Einige Wochen später.
Das Pflegezentrum Englischgruss
in Brig.
Mittlerweile
haben sieben der neun Kursabsolventen
eine feste Anstellung gefunden,
drei von ihnen arbeiten hier.
So auch Yari Osman,
ein 35-jähriger Kurde.
Ohne Zucker.
- Ohne Zucker.
Rivella, ist das gut?
* Stimmengewirr im Hintergrund *
Ein schweizweit anerkanntes Pflege-
helfer-Zertifikat des Roten Kreuzes
befähigt den Flüchtling aus dem Irak
zu dieser Arbeit.
Auch Schweizer
können dieses Zertifikat erwerben,
mit den gleichen Prüfungen,
doch deren Interesse ist eher gering.
Deshalb sind diese Flüchtlinge
für Schweizer keine Konkurrenz.
Im Gegenteil,
es herrscht ein Pflegenotstand,
über 10'000 Stellen in der Pflege
sind nicht besetzt.
* Langsame Handorgelmusik *
Gehen wir nach Hause?
- Ja.
Sich ein bisschen hinlegen.
(Natalie Zuwerrra) Die einzige
Frage, die ich mir stelle, ist:
"Möchte ich mich
von dieser Person pflegen lassen?"
Kann ich das bejahen,
dann spielt es für mich keine Rolle,
ob es ein Ausländer, ein Walliser,
ein Zürcher oder was auch immer ist.
Ich muss diese Frage
für mich beantworten.
Es stimmt für mich,
wenn sie empathisch sind
und den Zugang
zu den Menschen haben.
Nimm auch ein Glas,
dann können wir zusammen anstossen.
Merci, nein.
Ich arbeite, darf nicht trinken.
Doch, nur, nur, nur ...
... ein Glas nehmen.
- (Lachend) Merci.
Nein, nein, ich arbeite.
- Ja, gut.
Wären doch nur alle wie er ...
... von ... Mehr sage ich nicht.
Ich habe gesagt:
"Von allen, die da reinkommen,
sollten alle sein wie er,
dann wäre es schon gut.
(Pfleger) Merci.
- Bitte, das ist die Wahrheit.
Für solche Leute
haben wir immer Platz. 100 %.
Ehrlich, redlich und korrekt -
das ist er.
Für ihn würde ich auch
die Hand ins Feuer legen.
Ganz sicher, ganz sicher.
Auch Hibo Mohammed hat dank dem
Pflegekurs hier ein Arbeit gefunden.
Dabei sah es anfänglich eher düster
aus, denn die deutsche Sprache -
und dann noch der Walliser Dialekt -,
das war der 22-jährigen Frau
aus Somalia einfach zu fremd.
* Langgezogene Flötenklänge *
Am Urnersee bei Flüelen,
fast in Sichtweite zum Rütli,
wo, wie man sagt,
die Schweiz ihren Anfang nahm.
Einmal im Monat spielt Heinz Gerig
beim Schloss Rudenz
mit einigen Freunden Petanque.
Ich schiebe ihn auf die Seite,
dann ist die Sache geklärt.
Nein! Das ist deiner!
Nicht alle Stammbäume dieser Männer
reichen bis zum Rütli zurück.
Einige Vorfahren kamen
als italienische Gastarbeiter
zum Tunnel- und Autobahnbau
ins Land am Gotthard.
Geblieben
sind die italienischen Namen,
der Rest
ist längst urnerisch geworden.
... Muskeln um den Bauch,
Haare auf den Zähnen ...
... geputzt und gekämmt,
ich habe ihn.
Priis!
- (Alle) Priis!
Klar, die Einwanderung,
die neuen Fremden
sind auch hier
ein brennendes Thema.
Heinz Gerig, der auf allen
Kontinenten als Koch unterwegs war,
berichtet über ein Schlüsselerlebnis.
Ich hatte in Afrika
einen schweren Motorradunfall.
Ich erinnere mich nur noch an den
Unfall, sonst weiss ich nichts mehr.
Eine Hutu-Familie aus dem Busch
hat mich wieder zusammengeflickt.
Ich weiss nicht,
wie viele Monate ich dort war.
Aber keiner fragte:
"Wer ist das? Woher kommt der?"
Sie haben einfach gehandelt.
Das sind so Beispiele,
die mich auch dazu bewogen haben,
mich dafür einzusetzen.
Es gibt auch andere Beispiele:
"Sorry, diese Leute muss man
wieder nach Hause schicken,
denn sie verdienen es nicht."
Die Gastfreundschaft
muss man sich verdienen.
Ich weiss auch nicht,
welche die richtige ist.
Die Gastfreundschaft
muss man sich verdienen.
Dass so viele fremde Menschen
in die Schweiz kommen,
beschäftigt die Urner Männer.
Heinz Gerig
erzählt von seiner Arbeit.
Meine erste Frage lautet immer:
"Wieso die Schweiz?"
"Warum nicht England, Frankreich
Dänemark? Warum die Schweiz?"
Da antwortete mir einmal
ein Teilnehmer,
er habe im Internet eine Werbung
gesehen. Es war diese Sheba-Werbung:
Ein Butler
kommt mit dem Katzenfutterdose,
darauf eine goldene Glosche
und Petersilie.
Er habe sich gesagt: "Wenn die
so gut zu den Tieren schauen,
stell dir vor,
wie die zu den Menschen schauen!"
Das war ausschlaggebend,
das vergesse ich nie mehr.
Das sind Begehrlichkeiten,
die wir schaffen. - Ja.
Es ist ein zweischneidiges Schwert:
Er macht einen super Job.
Auch die Integration ist gut.
Aber man kann nicht so viele
aufnehmen und integrieren.
Es geht nicht um die Attraktivität,
die aber auch steigen kann.
Jeder von ihnen hat ein Handy,
ich habe nicht mal eines.
"Du musst kommen,
hier kannst du Geld verdienen!"
Wo fängt man an und wo hört man auf?
Ich habe das Gefühl,
da hat niemand eine Lösung.
Aber der Ansatz von Heinz
ist natürlich richtig.
Ohne die Integration der Leute
geht es nicht.
Ob es uns passt oder nicht:
Wir müssen versuchen,
sie zu integrieren.
Sie brauchen einen Job,
eine vernünftige Arbeit.
Man muss sie integrieren,
bezahlen muss man sowieso.
Und sonst geht es gar nicht.
Das gibt ein Ghetto.
Das gibt Probleme
wie andernorts auch,
wie z.B. in Frankreich.
Oder andernorts,
wo sie irgendwo abgeschottet werden.
* Heitere Akkordeonklänge *
* Flugzeuglärm *
Erneut versucht Heinz Gerig
bei seinen Schülern
den Sinn für Werte und Normen
zu schärfen,
zu zeigen, dass das, was hier gilt,
andernorts unverständlich ist.
Und umgekehrt.
Auf allzu grosse Feinheiten
kann er bei seiner Weltreise
allerdings keine Rücksicht nehmen.
Wenn Sie durch die Welt reisen,
dann können Sie
ganz böse Überraschungen erleben.
Heinz Gerig
malt mit dem breiten Pinsel.
... Servicefachmann,
Servicefachfrau.
In China ist es absolut normal,
dass man überall  ...
* Spuckgeräusche *
... auf den Boden spuckt.
Wenn Sie in Brasilien sind,
dann dürfen Sie  n i e
persönliche Fragen stellen.
Alles, was persönlich ist,
ist ein Tabu.
Und das ist typisch Deutschland.
Nicht?
Nur Deutsche kommen auf die Idee,
irgendwo auf dieser Welt
in die Ferien zu gehen, sich nackt
in den Sand zu setzen: "Da bin ich."
* Lachen *
Kein anderes Land würde das machen,
aber die Deutschen machen das.
Darum denken Sie bitte immer daran:
Werte und Normen -
das ist nicht richtig oder falsch.
In diesem Land ist es so,
und in dem Land ist es so.
Am besten ist es, wenn Sie
in dem Land, in dem Sie sind,
das annehmen,
was in diesem Land normal ist.
* Quirlige Musik *
Von den Wänden
lächeln den Flüchtlingen
die beruflichen Vorbilder entgegen:
schöne, glückliche Menschen.
Sieht bald so
auch das eigene Leben aus?
Was mache ich mit der Bürste?
- (Diverse) Reinigen. - Reinigen.
Einmal rundum.
Wozu dient das da? - Für unten.
- Unter den Rand.
Sehr gut.
Sie müssen auch kontrollieren, dass
es WC-Rollen hat, eine als Reserve.
Und eine da.
Es gibt nichts Schlimmeres,
als ohne WC-Papier
auf der Toilette zu sitzen.
Das ist Ihnen
evtl. schon mal passiert.
Stellen Sie sich vor, das passiert
einem Gast. Das ist peinlich.
Der kommt nicht mehr.
Der kommt nie mehr.
Entschuldigung!
Wie machen wir das mit dem Papier?
Wir können es einmal etwas falten.
Dann machen wir so einen Spitz.
Ganz einfach,
und dann nur eindrehen.
Wer kann mir sagen, warum man
am Schluss einen Spitz macht?
Weil das ist ... die Begrüssung.
Wir haben auch schon so
Toiletten geputzt.
Wenn Sie so eingefaltetes
Toilettenpapier sehen,
dann wissen Sie automatisch:
"Aha, diese Toilette ist gereinigt."
"Die ist sauber."
Hat noch jemand eine Frage?
- Ja.
(In gebrochenem Deutsch)
War das die ganze Reinigung?
Das war
eine tägliche Toilettenreinigung.
Ah, täglich.
Es gibt noch eine gründliche ...
also eine Zwischenreinigung,
eine Grundreinigung.
Dann könnte es noch
eine Saisonreinigung geben.
Ja, ja?
- Ja, ja!
* Drollige Musik *
* Abruptes Ende der Musik *
Das Leben in der Schweiz
begann für Tashi Tashitsang
2013 im Asylempfangszentrum
Kreuzlingen.
Der Tibeter war 17 Jahre alt.
Ein junger Mann
ohne jegliche Schulbildung,
doch offenbar intelligent
und mit einem starken Willen,
es hier zu schaffen.
Er verstand kein Wort Deutsch, musste
das Lesen lernen und das Schreiben.
Haben Sie überhaupt gewusst,
dass es die Schweiz gibt?
(In gebrochenem Deutsch)
Amerika kannten Sie.
- Genau.
Sie sind seit zwei Jahren
in der Schweiz.
Was haben Sie für Zukunftsträume?
Für meine Zukunft ...
Tashi Tashitsang -
geflohen als Jugendlicher
vor der chinesischen Unterdrückung
in seiner Heimat.
Angekommen nach einer langen,
gefährlichen Reise
im Luzerner Hinterland.
* Vogelzwitschern *
Ich habe nichts gehört.
In Altishofen bewohnt Tashi mit zwei
Landsleuten eine gemeinsame Wohnung.
Das Rezept für die tibetischen
Teigtaschen stammt von seiner Mutter,
mit der er
nicht in Kontakt treten darf,
weil er sie sonst gefährden würde.
Wenn Tashi
nach Hause schreiben könnte,
wie würde er seinen Eltern
die Schweiz schildern?
(In gebrochenem Deutsch)
Es ist sehr gut.
Haut das Ding voll in die Torwart-
ecke! Mal sehen, wie er reagiert.
Hört auf, zu zaubern!
Übersetzt du für ihn? Ich will
nicht alles auf Hochdeutsch ...
(Mann) Heute schauen wir
zuerst die Theorie an.
Eckbälle und Freistösse.
Seit einigen Monaten trainiert Tashi
bei den A-Junioren
vom Team Wiggertal.
Hier spricht man Schweizerdeutsch.
(In gebrochenem Deutsch)
Auch Fussball hat Tashi
erst in der Schweiz kennengelernt.
Fussball,
die grosse Integrationsmaschine.
* Quirlige Akkordeonklänge,
gemischt mit dumpfen Basstönen *
Etwas ausserhalb von Luzern:
das Seehotel Hermitage.
Letzter Tag des Küchenpraktikums
von Tashi Tashitsang.
Der Anfang war hart.
Todmüde war der junge Tibeter
jeweils abends,
bleischwer waren die Knochen.
Doch er hat's durchgestanden.
Der Küchenchef ist sehr zufrieden.
Ich muss sagen, ich bin begeistert
von Ihnen. An Ihnen gefällt mir,
dass Sie sehr aufnahmefähig sind.
Man kann Ihnen etwas erklären,
zeigen oder vormachen,
und Sie setzen das dann
sehr spielerisch und leicht um.
Das haben Sie toll gemacht.
Sie sind mit Elan drangeblieben.
Und was mir v.a. auch sehr gefällt:
immer mit einem Lächeln
und immer sehr motiviert.
(In gebrochenem Deutsch) Ich arbeite
zum ersten Mal in einer Küche.
Jetzt habe ich viel Erfahrung,
und ich konnte so viel lernen.
Ich bin sehr zufrieden.
Tashi Tashitsang hat den RIESCO-Kurs
einige Tage vor dem Ende verlassen.
Und dieser Abgang des 19-Jährigen
ist eine Erfolgsmeldung:
Tashi hat selber eine Stelle gesucht
und diese im Luzerner Restaurant
Tibits bekommen.
Wer eine Anstellung findet, darf
den RIESCO-Kurs jederzeit verlassen.
Aus dem einstigen
tibetischen Bauernjungen
ist ein adretter Kellner geworden.
(In gebrochenem Deutsch)
Die Getränke, die Namen ...
Die sind ein bisschen schwierig.
Und ein bisschen
mit dem Gast zu reden,
fand ich schwierig.
Tashi hat sein Ziel erreicht.
Doch es bleibt
der sehnlichste Wunsch,
dass er bald in Kontakt
mit seinen Eltern treten kann,
die in der tibetischen Heimat
unter chinesischer Besatzung leben.
Seit vier Jahren hat der 19-Jährige
nichts mehr von ihnen gehört.
Heute lebt Tashi Tashitsang in einem
ruhigen Aussenquartier von Luzern.
Die Bauprofile zeigen, dass es
nur eine vorübergehende Bleibe ist.
Es ist sein arbeitsfreier Tag
und Tashi hat einen tibetischen
Kollegen zum Brunch eingeladen.
* Stimmengewirr *
* Aufgestellte, tibetische Musik *
In den vergangenen vier Jahren
hat sich Wichtiges verändert
für den tibetischen Flüchtling,
verändert zum Guten.
Seine Eltern konnten aus Tibet
fliehen, mitsamt den Kindern.
Heute leben sie als Flüchtlinge
in Indien.
Tashi konnte zu ihnen reisen.
Nach vielen Jahren
der schmerzvollen Ungewissheit
konnte er seine Mutter wiedersehen.
(In gebrochenem Deutsch)
Das ist meine Mutter.
Als ich in Indien war.
Es war sehr schwierig.
Weil ich so gross geworden bin,
hat sie mich beinahe nicht erkannt.
Für mich war es auch so ...
Ich hatte ein trauriges,
aber auch ein glückliches Gefühl.
Sie hat mich erst nicht erkannt.
Ich habe sie erkannt.
Ich habe gesehen,
dass meine Mutter da ist.
Ich bin zu ihr gegangen
und sie sagte mir,
sie sei ein bisschen nervös.
Sie hat gewusst, dass ich komme.
Und, ja ...
Es war ein guter Moment.
Mein jüngster Bruder
ist mit ihr gekommen.
Ich bin neben ihm.
Wir sind immer im Hotel geblieben.
Und dann ...
Das ist mein Vater.
Aber auch in Indien ist
die tibetische Exilgemeinde bedroht.
Der indische Präsident empfängt
seinen chinesischen Amtskollegen
und er unternimmt alles, um den
mächtigen Nachbarn nicht zu erzürnen.
So werden Tibeter
vorsorglich ins Gefängnis gesteckt.
* Kampfgebrüll und Schreie
aus dem Fernseher *
Das ist traurig für mich.
Es ist so traurig,
dass das gemacht wird.
Aber momentan wohnen meine Eltern
an einem anderen Ort in Indien.
Ihnen geht es im Moment gut.
Aber, ja ...
Wir sind eine Familie,
und wir sind Tibeter.
Geht es einem Tibeter nicht gut,
geht es den anderen auch nicht gut.
Darum ist es wirklich traurig.
In einer Luzerner Landgemeinde.
Helen Meyer und ihr Mann
haben sich mit Tashi angefreundet.
Das Schicksal des jungen Flüchtlings
hat sie berührt.
Heute hilft Helen Meyer dem Tibeter
beim Gesuch
für eine Aufenthaltsbewilligung,
einer sog. B-Bewilligung.
Die bürokratischen Hürden
sind sehr hoch.
Du brauchst auch einen Betreibungs-
auszug der letzten fünf Jahre.
Den musst du persönlich abholen.
- Ja.
Du musst den Auszug aus
dem Zentralstrafregister bestellen.
Was du auch einreichen musst ...
... ist der Mietzins deiner Wohnung
und eine Bestätigung
von deinem Arbeitgeber.
Kein Zeugnis, sondern dass
dein Arbeitsvertrag unbefristet ist,
dass du weiterarbeiten kannst und
das nicht nur bis Ende Jahr gilt.
Wir müssen auch die Lohnabrechnungen
der letzten zwölf Monate
einschicken,
die du von deinem Arbeitgeber
erhalten hast.
Bankkonto ...
Du musst alle Bankauszüge
der letzten zwölf Monate
von deinem Postcheckkonto
ausdrucken.
Wir haben das Gesuch
letztes Jahr eingereicht.
Man kann es frühestens
nach fünf Jahren einreichen.
Leider haben wir einen
negativen Entscheid erhalten.
Mit welcher Begründung?
Bei einem negativen Entscheid
erhält man keine Begründung.
Auch wenn man
telefonisch nachfragt,
erhält man eigentlich
keine genaue Begründung.
Sie machen es noch einmal.
Mit welcher Hoffnung
oder mit welchen neuen Antworten?
Wir hoffen natürlich,
dass wir dieses Mal mehr Glück haben
und Tashi die B-Bewilligung erhält.
Es haben sich Dinge verändert,
v.a. sein Deutsch.
Er hat Deutschkurse besucht.
Inzwischen hat er ein B1-Diplom.
Er ist bei der Arbeit
sehr engagiert.
Er hat gute Arbeitszeugnisse
erhalten.
Er kennt mehr Leute,
ist immer besser integriert.
So hoffen wir,
dass es dieses Mal klappt.
Warum dieses grosse Bemühen
um eine B-Bewilligung?
(In gebrochenem Deutsch)
Wenn ich eine B-Bewilligung erhalte,
habe ich mehr Chancen,
im Leben etwas erreichen zu können.
Im Moment habe ich
eine F-Bewilligung.
Damit ist es z.B. auch schwierig,
eine Lehre machen zu können.
Es ist wirklich sehr schwierig.
Jetzt ist er vorläufig aufgenommen.
D.h., es ist nicht sicher,
dass er hierbleiben kann.
Mit einer B-Bewilligung
kann er sicher hierbleiben.
Es hilft ihm auch
bei der Wohnungssuche.
Es gibt Vermieter,
gerade auch Genossenschaften,
die niemanden nehmen,
der keine B-Bewilligung hat.
Dabei geht es ja v.a.
auch um die günstigen Wohnungen.
Es gibt Arbeitgeber, die für eine
Stelle eine B-Bewilligung wollen.
Sie wollen einfach sicher sein,
dass die Leute hierbleiben.
Und so kämpft man sich weiter
durch den Fragekatalog
der Migrationsbehörde.
Keine einfache Sache,
in der Schweiz anzukommen.
Warum leistet Helen Meyer
diese Unterstützung?
Es sind Flüchtlinge,
sie mussten Tibet verlassen
und leben jetzt bei uns.
Ich finde es einfach wichtig,
dass man diese Leute
in der Integration unterstützt.
Es braucht auch den Willen von uns,
von uns Schweizern.
Wir müssen auf die Leute zugehen
und ihnen helfen.
Sie können sich nur integrieren,
wenn auch wir mitmachen.
Du spielst Fussball in einem Verein.
- Genau, ja.
Wir brauchen auch eine Bestätigung,
dass du dort Mitglied bist
und dass du dort mitmachst.
Das ist gut, was wir haben
und was wir noch brauchen.
Genau.
* Langgezogene Streicherklänge *
Frühmorgendliche Fahrt
durch die Zentralschweiz.
Ein Kleinbus
voller junger Männer,
unter ihnen auch Tashi Tashitsang,
mittlerweile Spieler
beim FC Tibet Pilatus.
Am Steuer
der einzige Nicht-Tibeter,
Michel Ouwehand,
der holländische Fussballtrainer.
Am Hintereingang von Luzern steuert
der Bus einen Zwischenstopp an.
Hier werden weitere Passagiere
aufgeladen.
* Vogelzwitschern, Stimmengewirr *
In einer schäbigen Hüttensiedlung
leben einige Dutzend
abgewiesener Asylbewerber -
darunter auch Spieler
der tibetischen Mannschaft.
* Tibetischer Gesang *
Heute ist das klare Ziel,
den Cup zu holen.
Einfach alles daransetzen,
um den Cup zu holen.
So wie im letzten Training.
Am Anfang haben wir nicht
gut gespielt, nachher lief es super.
Junge Tibeter,
alle mit einer ähnlichen Biografie -
doch mit unterschiedlichen
Asylentscheiden.
Einige glückliche, wie Tashi,
können Fuss fassen in der Schweiz.
Andere hier haben
ein ablehnendes Urteil erhalten,
sind zu Illegalen erklärt worden.
Doch heute gilt nur das Ballglück.
Vielleicht reicht es sogar zu Gold.
22 tibetische Mannschaften
aus der ganzen Schweiz kämpfen darum.
Sie heissen FC Himalaya Zürich,
Lhasa Boys
oder eben FC Tibet Pilatus
aus Sarnen.
Namen, die verraten,
dass diese jungen Menschen
ihre Heimat nicht vergessen haben -
eine Heimat, in die sie wohl
nie mehr werden zurückkehren können.
* Jubelschreie *
2:0. Super, Jungs!
* Langgezogene Akkordeonklänge *
* Stimmengewirr *
* Quietschen der Eisenbahnbremsen *
Willst du lieber
die Kaffeemaschine putzen
oder das Mise en Place machen?
Du kannst wählen.
Lieber Mise en Place.
Und, das habe ich gesagt.
Bis spätestens 18 Uhr müssen wir ...
Wir müssen schauen,
dass die Zitronen ...
Tashi Tashitsang
hat sich beruflich verbessert.
Im Restaurant Tibits
im Luzerner Bahnhof,
wo er seit vier Jahren,
seit dem RIESCO-Kurs arbeitet,
hilft er nun
bei der Einführung von Neulingen.
(Tashi) Fragen, fragen, fragen.
Bis du sagst: "Ja, ich weiss es."
Dann ist gut.
* Tashi lacht. *
Möchten Sie die Grosse
oder die Kleine haben?
Ich zeige es Ihnen:
Das ist gross und das ist klein.
Klein, super.
Achtung!
Darf ich es Ihnen so geben?
Danke schön
und noch einen schönen Tag.
Grüezi wohl.
So.
7.40 Fr. bitte, Madame.
4.30 Fr., please.
Haben Sie etwas gefunden?
Grüezi wohl. Was darf ich Ihnen ...
- Gerne ein Ingwer-Zitronen-Saft.
Sehr gerne.
Sehr schön, ich gebe Ihnen
die Quittung mit, Madame.
Wenn Sie ein Brötchen möchten,
können Sie sich am Buffet bedienen.
* Drollige Musik, Stimmengewirr *
Kürbis-Cappuccino ...
Entschuldigung.
Super, vielen Dank.
Danke schön.
* Drollige Musik, Stimmengewirr *
Heute verdient sich
der tibetische Flüchtling
seinen Lebensunterhalt selbst -
und es bleibt auch noch etwas Geld,
das er seinen Eltern
nach Indien schicken kann.
Der Bauernbub ohne Schulbildung
hat sich viel erkämpft.
So bald wie möglich
möchte er eine Lehre machen.
Und da sind noch grössere Pläne.
(In gebrochenem Deutsch)
Ich möchte selbstständig werden.
Dass ich etwas Eigenes ...
Ich möchte irgendwo ein kleines
Take-away-Restaurant führen.
Dann könnte ich
selbstständig arbeiten.
So habe ich einen Plan
für die Zukunft.
Noch einen schönen Abend.
Tschüss zusammen, danke!
* Dumpfer, langgezogener Klang *
Roger Leuthold
leitet den RIESCO-Servicekurs.
Seit seinem dritten Lebensjahr sei er
der Gastronomie verfallen, sagt er.
Servieren,
das sei der beste Beruf der Welt.
Und das will er seinen Schülern
mit allen Mitteln verdeutlichen.
Ich komme zum Gast und frage:
"Sind Sie bedient?
Darf ich abräumen?"
"Sind Sie bedient?"
"Darf ich abräumen?"
Ich nehme diesen Teller
wieder mit der rechten Hand,
nicht mit der linken.
Wieder mit der rechten Hand auf ...
... und übergebe ihn wieder
der linken Hand.
Es ist ein reines Pingpong,
ein Hin und Her.
Für die Menschen aus Afrika und Asien
bedeutet all das eine neue Welt.
Wir haben einen Teller für alles:
für Salat, fürs Essen.
In der Schweiz
haben wir verschiedene Teller,
verschiedene Gläser,
Gabel und Messer.
Wir laufen nun gemeinsam
in die sechste Etage.
Erste Etage!
* Lachen, Stimmengewirr *
* Sanfte Akkordeonmusik,
Klappern der Teller *
Vierte Etage.
Sechste Etage.
Es ist die zweite Woche
im Servicekurs,
und die RIESCO-Leiter
müssen notfallmässig anreisen.
Die Klasse ist verzweifelt.
Die Flüchtlinge fühlen sich
überfordert: zu viele Fachausdrücke,
davon die meisten
in unverständlichem Französisch.
Das Problem ist,
nichts zu verstehen.
Sie haben in einem Jahr ...
Was haben Sie alles gelernt?
Werte und Normen,
Stärken und Schwächen.
Sie haben gelernt, Teile ...
Hauswirtschaft, Küche.
Überall hat es Fachwörter.
Jetzt kommen neue Fachwörter dazu.
Sie dürfen nicht denken,
dass Sie sich alles
sofort merken können.
Wir wollen nicht, dass Sie uns
zehn Weissweine aufzählen können.
Wenn Sie mir zwei sagen können,
bin ich happy.
Mehr brauche ich nicht.
Sie müssen mir auch nicht
sämtliche Trauben erklären können.
Aber Sie müssen wissen,
dass es einen weissen Wein gibt,
einen roten und einen Rose.
Heinz Gerig ist gefordert.
Er muss die verunsicherte Klasse
wieder ins Boot holen.
Ich habe eine Lösung.
Wann immer Sie die Situation haben,
dass Sie etwas nicht verstehen,
machen Sie so und dann weiss
Herr Leuthold: "Halt! Stopp!"
Dann wird er von nun an fragen:
"Was verstehen Sie nicht?"
Berekat Tesefay, ein besonders
pflichtbewusster Schüler,
hatte den Serviceunterricht
sogar weinend verlassen.
Nicht davonlaufen.
Wenn Sie das am Arbeitsplatz machen,
würde das niemand verstehen.
(In gebrochenem Deutsch)
Ja, also ...
Ich spüre,
dass Sie ein bisschen Zeit
für sich brauchen.
Gehen Sie heute nach Hause,
und morgen kommen Sie ganz normal.
Ist das gut?
Dann können Sie
ein bisschen runterfahren.
Berekat Tesefay,
Flüchtling aus Eritrea,
wird nach dem Kurs
eine Anstellung finden
in einem Fünfsternehotel
in der Innerschweiz.
Sie sind sehr vorbildlich.
In einer Woche
schaue ich wieder vorbei,
und dann werden wir Sie fragen.
Ich glaube,
so haben wir eine Lösung.
Gut?
- Ja.
* Strassenlärm *
In der Küche des Hotels
Waldstätterhof in Luzern.
Seit Jahren schon können
Flüchtlinge aus dem RIESCO-Kurs
hier die Realität kennenlernen.
Übung macht den Meister.
Es ist die zweite Woche
des Küchenpraktikums
für den Afghanen Isa Villayaty.
Er hat in diesem Hotel bereits
das Hauswirtschaftspraktikum gemacht.
Der Afghane ist glücklich,
dass er hier arbeiten darf.
Doch da ist immer auch
eine tiefe Melancholie.
(In gebrochenem Deutsch)
Ich bin traurig,
weil ich mein Land vermisse.
Dort kenne ich
die Sprache der Leute.
Ich kann besser
mit den Leuten sprechen.
Aber hier ...
Ich spreche nicht gut Deutsch oder
ich kenne die Sprache nicht gut.
Darum kann ich nicht
mit den Leuten in Kontakt treten.
Aber das ...
Deswegen bin ich traurig.
Mein Land ist besser für mich.
Ich muss in meinem Land sein,
aber leider ist in meinem Land
immer Krieg - immer Krieg.
Grausam ist die Lebensgeschichte
von Isa Villayaty.
Doch seine Liebenswürdigkeit
liess er sich nicht nehmen.
Er ist ein sehr lieber Mensch.
Wir alle haben das hier gemerkt.
In der Küche, im Service -
alle sagen das.
Isa Villayaty, der Afghane, in einer
gänzlich anderen Kultur angekommen.
Am Stadtrand von Luzern,
viel Verkehr, viele Ausländer.
Hier hat Isa Villayaty
eine Wohnung gefunden.
(In gebrochenem Deutsch)
Hier ist es sehr laut wegen ...
Der Zug fährt hier,
der Bus fährt hier.
Deshalb wohnen Schweizer
nicht an solchen Orten.
Die meisten hier sind Flüchtlinge.
Flüchtlinge aus Eritrea, Somalia,
aus Afrika z.B.
Aus Asien.
Es gibt viele Tibeter, Afghanen,
Pakistaner, Inder, Singhalesen -
wir sind alle hier.
Ich habe hier noch nie
einen Schweizer gesehen.
Alle Schweizer wohnen im Dorf.
Oder an einem schönen Ort.
Aber von dieser Wohnung,
von diesem Gebäude
hat man eine schöne Aussicht.
Das finde ich sehr gut.
Man hat immer frische Luft.
Isa Villayaty, immer noch
in der Gastrobranche arbeitstätig,
ein zufriedener Mensch.
Ich bin stolz auf mich.
Ich bin eine selbstständige Person.
Ich fühle mich sehr gut.
(In gebrochenem Deutsch)
Zuvor habe ich Sozialhilfe erhalten,
was sehr gut war.
Seit fast drei Jahren ...
... bin ich
eine selbstständige Person.
Ich bezahle
meine Krankenkasse selbst.
die Wohnungsmiete selbst.
Und ich bezahle mein Essen selbst.
Und ich habe genügend Lohn.
Ich habe genügend Lohn für mich.
Das hier lese ich jeden Tag.
"Der Natur- und Tierpark Goldau".
Ich muss mein Deutsch verbessern.
Das ist sehr wichtig.
Wenn ich in der Zukunft
eine Chance bekomme,
dann mache ich sicher
eine Kochlehre.
Ich habe gerne
in der Küche gearbeitet.
Und da ist Alja, 28 Jahre alt,
Isas Verlobte in Pakistan,
die er allerdings
erst übers Internet kennt.
(In gebrochenem Deutsch)
Meine Frau ... hat meine ...
Meine Stiefmutter
hat sie für mich gesucht ...
... gesehen oder so.
Sie ist sicher sehr schön,
meine Frau ist sehr schön.
Und ich heirate.
Diese Zweizimmerwohnung
ist gross genug für mich.
Das reicht für mich und meine Frau.
Dort arbeiten die Frauen nicht.
Es ist verboten,
man kann nicht arbeiten.
Ich habe meiner Frau
jeden Tag gesagt:
"Wenn du in die Schweiz kommst,
kannst du ein bisschen arbeiten,
das ist gut für unser Leben."
Sie sagt: "Ja, okay. Ich komme
und versuche zu arbeiten."
Und irgendwann
soll es ein Fest geben.
Dann will Isa Villayaty
nach Pakistan reisen,
um seine schöne Frau zu heiraten.
* Schnelle Handorgelmusik *
Der Waldstätterhof
beim Bahnhof Luzern.
Das schmucke Dreisternehotel
ist seit vier Jahren
der Arbeitsplatz von Isa Villayaty.
Hier, wo er bereits
das RIESCO-Praktikum gemacht hat.
* Er summt ein Lied. *
Zehn Leute arbeiten in der Küche,
Menschen aus sieben Ländern.
Und im ganzen Hotelunternehmen sind
es noch einige Nationalitäten mehr.
Der multikulturelle Betrieb
wird von Susanne Graber
und ihrem Mann geführt.
Sie werden nie
einen Schweizer finden,
der bei uns Teller wäscht
und in der Küche Pfannen putzt
und Zimmer reinigt.
Wir finden kaum mehr Leute.
Ist es eine Lohnfrage? Würden Sie
einen Schweizer besser bezahlen?
Nein, wir haben
unsere Löhne im Gastgewerbe
nicht auf die Nationalitäten abge-
stimmt, sondern auf die Ausbildung.
Wir halten uns
an den Gesamtarbeitsvertrag.
Noch bevor der grosse Mittagssturm
in der Küche losbricht,
versammelt sich das Personal
in der Kantine zum Essen.
Und auch das ist eine Kulturfrage.
Schweinefleisch etwa ist dem Muslim
Isa Villayaty nicht bekömmlich.
Und eigentlich verböte der Islam
jetzt, im Ramadan,
überhaupt das Essen
zu dieser Tageszeit.
(In gebrochenem Deutsch)
Bei uns ist es erlaubt,
wenn jemand ein Problem hat:
wenn jemand krank ist.
Oder wenn jemand z.B.
eine Reise macht.
Oder wenn jemand schwer arbeitet.
Dann ist es kein Problem.
Der Ramadan, das islamische Fasten,
wäre mit den Anforderungen,
die in der Schweizer Küche
gestellt werden, kaum vereinbar.
Bei körperlicher Arbeit
dürfen sie ihn nicht einhalten.
Nicht, weil wir etwas dagegen haben,
sondern weil die Kräfte fehlen.
Wenn sie im Sommer
weder essen noch trinken,
können sie nicht arbeiten.
* Gemütliche Handorgelmusik *
Und so kommen hier
viele Geschichten zusammen,
schöne, aber auch traumatische,
von einer Art,
die das Schweizer Vorstellungs-
vermögen übersteigen kann.
Ich hatte schon eine Frau hier,
deren RIESCO-Praktikum
wir abbrechen mussten.
Sie ist in ihrem Heimatland
mehrfach vergewaltigt worden.
Sie litt unter Verfolgungswahn.
Sie konnte nicht
in einem Zimmer arbeiten,
in dem ein Mann staubsaugte
und ein anderer das Fenster putzte.
Das ist sicher ein Thema.
Oft sind es Männer,
die unter Verfolgungswahn leiden.
Wir haben welche,
die psychologisch betreut werden.
Mit einigen haben wir es geschafft,
den Weg weiterzugehen,
mit anderen mussten wir ihn
leider abbrechen.
* Sanftes Vogelzwitschern *
Im Luzerner Grand Hotel National
beginnt im RIESCO-Kurs Ali Hashemi
sein Hauswirtschaftspraktikum.
Die Abläufe scheinen klar und simpel.
In einem solch gehobenen Haus sind
selbst beim Bettenmachen und Putzen
viele Finessen zu beachten.
* Drollige Klarinettenklänge *
Sie können kontrollieren
ob das gut ist.
Ein charmanter, junger Mann,
aufgeweckt
und mit guter Arbeitsleistung.
Doch mit den Regeln des RIESCO-Kurses
kommt er nicht klar.
Zu oft fehlt er unentschuldigt,
schliesslich verliert er
diese Praktikumsstelle.
(Heinz Gerig)
Dieser Kurs kostet viel Geld.
Und da draussen gibt es Hunderte,
die das auch gerne machen würden.
(Eindringlich) Und darum wollen wir
nur die richtigen Leute in dem Kurs.
Sonst ist das Geld
falsch investiert.
Wir können es
aus dem Fenster werfen,
dann haben wir genau gleich viel,
und das möchte ich nicht.
Der 19-jährige Afghane
versiebt auch noch die letzte Chance.
Er muss den RIESCO-Kurs
schliesslich verlassen.
Auf dem Sportplatz in Willisau,
wo er früher Fussball spielte,
ringt er um eine Erklärung.
Das war mein Fehler.
Ich habe nicht mitgemacht,
obwohl ich die Chance hatte.
Ich bedanke mich bei Herrn Gerig,
dass er mir
diese Chance gegeben hat.
Ich habe es trotzdem nicht gesehen.
Ich habe einfach das gemacht,
was ich im Kopf hatte.
Die Schweiz ist ...
... das einzig beste Land, in dem
man eine Ausbildung machen kann.
Aber  S i e  müssen es packen.
(Lachend) Ich bin dran.
Ali Hashemi, mittlerweile
Vater eines kleinen Sohnes,
arbeitet nach dem RIESCO-Kurs
zeitweise auf dem Bau,
dann ist er wieder ohne Arbeit.
* Langgezogene Streicherklänge *
In Emmenbrücke
versammelt sich die Klasse,
um die vergangenen Praktikumswochen
zu besprechen.
Auch Saba Zeray ist
aus ihrem Praktikum zurückgekehrt.
Die Eritreerin ist
mit einer traumatischen Bootsfahrt
übers Mittelmeer nach Europa gelangt.
Jetzt hofft sie, wie alle hier,
ihr Leben in der Schweiz
verbessern zu können.
Wie hat mir das Praktikum gefallen?
Auf der einen Seite ...
... oder überhaupt nicht gefallen.
Und dann, warum?
Die meisten waren sehr zufrieden,
viele gar zu 100 %.
Kursleiter Heinz Gerig
kann es kaum glauben.
Jetzt wird es mir
langsam unheimlich.
Wieder 100 %.
Auch Saba Zeray
hatte fünf gute Praktikumswochen -
einzig ein Erlebnis betrübte sie.
Frau Zeray,
Sie haben das super gelöst.
Sie haben im Prinzip
die eine Antwort schon gegeben.
Diese Frau hatte Angst.
Sie ist eine Konkurrentin.
Die haben alle Angst,
dass Sie besser sind.
Wenn Sie besser sind,
erhalten Sie die Stelle.
Wir wollen nur die Besten
im Arbeitsmarkt.
Die Rückmeldungen der Praktikums-
betriebe klingen durchzogen.
"Die Person wirkt sehr unmotiviert."
"Die Person ist nicht belastbar,
wird schnell müde,
und immer tut etwas weh."
Der Rücken schmerzt, die Beine
schmerzen - das ist normal.
Was mir sehr gut gefallen hat:
Ich habe viele,
viele Rückmeldungen erhalten,
dass die persönliche Hygiene
sehr gut war.
Das hat mich wahnsinnig gefreut.
Ich weiss, wo Sie herkommen,
da ist die Arbeit komplett anders.
Jetzt kommen Sie in
ein komisches System wie die Schweiz
und müssen von irgendwo
auf 100-150 %
Das ist nicht einfach.
Das braucht Zeit,
aber man muss es schaffen.
Die Hoffnungen von Saba Zeray
werden sich vorerst nicht erfüllen.
Ihre Arbeit nach dem Kurs wird sie -
krankheitsbedingt - aufgeben müssen.
* Sanfte,
schwermütige Handorgelmusik *
Das Schuljahr
ist fast schon überstanden,
da werden die Flüchtlinge
noch aufs Glatteis geführt.
Wenn Sie umfallen, kein Problem.
Es ist wie im richtigen Leben:
Stehen Sie wieder auf
und machen Sie weiter!
Diese Männer und Frauen haben schon
Gewaltmärsche durch den Himalaya,
den Irrsinn der Taliban
und lebensbedrohliche Bootspassagen
auf dem Mittelmeer überlebt.
Da werden sie auch noch das Luzerner
Glatteis überstehen - irgendwie.
Sie müssen das Gewicht
nach vorne lagern.
Und wenn es einen Sturz gibt ...
Besser nach vorne als nach hinten.
- Ja.
Moses Kigozi, Journalist
und Menschenrechtsaktivist,
der aus seiner Heimat Uganda fliehen
musste - und nun, mit etwas Hilfe,
in kleinsten Schritten unterwegs
auf fremdem Terrain.
* Gemächliche Handorgelmusik *
* Stimmengewirr und Lachen
im Hintergrund *
Immer wieder aufstehen,
wie im richtigen Leben.
Das haben sie alle schon gemacht,
sonst wären sie nicht hier.
(Heinz Gerig) Guten Morgen!
Nervös?
- (Frau) Nervös.
Nervös? - (Mann) Wir sind nervös.
- Das soll so sein.
Die Prüfung ist nicht einfach.
Wir wollen viel wissen.
Wir wollen mehr wissen,
als es manchmal
vielleicht nötig ist - aber:
Je mehr Sie wissen, umso besser
wird es Ihnen nachher gehen.
Die Schüler sind angespannt.
In zwei Tagen
ist das Schuljahr zu Ende.
Heute sind die Abschlussprüfungen
in den Fächern Service und Kochen.
(Mann) Wir beginnen
mit dem Erscheinungsbild.
Die Fliege ist gut, die Hose ...
Die Socken
schauen wir uns noch kurz an.
Ja, das ist prima.
Unten das dunkle Bild
und oben ist das helle, weisse Bild,
aufgehellt durch die Fliege.
Die Fingernägel.
Die sehen gut, kurz aus. Jawohl.
Das ist ein Glas für Kaffee fertig.
- Für Kaffee fertig, genau.
Wie heisst dieses Glas?
- Whiskyglas oder Tumbler.
Whisky-Tumbler.
- Whisky-Tumbler. - Genau.
Das ist ein Tier, das ...
Ah, Schnecke. Schnecke.
Wie heiss diese Gabel?
- Schneckengabel.
Schneckengabel. Damit nimmt man sie
aus dem Häuschen.
Ja, genau. Das ist Geschmacksache.
In der Küche im Untergeschoss macht
sich die andere Hälfte der Klasse
für die Kochprüfung bereit:
Ein Viergangmenü soll's geben.
* Rascheln *
Die Zubereitung ist klar?
- (Mann) Alles klar.
Ich habe die Töpfchen hingestellt.
Suppe nach Bauernart.
Dies einer der Gänge
des Prüfungsmenüs.
Das ist genug?
Ja.
Der Mann aus Uganda
muss den Küchenchef spielen.
Moses Kigozi hat schon Pläne
für die Zeit nach RIESCO:
Er möchte an der Luzerner Hochschule
einen englischsprachigen
Tourismus-Lehrgang beginnen.
Das Ziel von Moses Kigozi:
von der Sozialhilfe wegkommen,
die Selbständigkeit erlangen.
Vier Jahre später.
Das Park Hotel Vitznau,
eine der besten Adressen
am Vierwaldstättersee.
(In gebrochenem Deutsch) Heute muss
ich alles alleine schaffen.
Mein Kollege ist nicht da.
Bis 11 Uhr muss alles bereit sein.
Die Kantine, die Getränke ...
... Brot, Suppe, die Speisen -
alles vorbereitet.
Und dann, ja ...
Wenn man schnell arbeitet, geht es.
Mittlerweile hat Moses Kigozi
eine beeindruckende
berufliche Karriere gemacht:
Der Flüchtling aus Afrika
leitet das Personalrestaurant
des Fünfsterne-Hauses.
* Quirlige Mundharmonikaklänge,
Murmeln *
Ich muss gut putzen.
So.
Wenn meine Gäste kommen,
ist alles sauber.
* Rasche Handorgelmusik *
Schnell, schnell.
* Rasante Handorgelmusik *
Alles bereit.
Es ist 11 Uhr.
Ein Teller,
oder willst du nur Salat?
Heute gibt es Salzkartoffeln,
Spiegelei, Hackbraten an Senfsauce.
Was braucht es, um in
der fremden Schweiz zurechtzukommen?
Man muss selbst daran glauben,
dass man das erreichen kann.
Dann ist alles tipptopp.
Das Zweite ist die Disziplin.
Ohne Disziplin kommt man
in der Schweiz nicht weiter.
* Handorgelmusik,
einsetzendes, sanftes Summen *
Und Moses Kigozi
möchte noch weiter kommen.
Einen Tourismus-Master der Hochschule
Luzern hat er bereits erworben.
Nun will er sich
auch in der Küche verbessern -
in diesem Weiterbildungskurs
für Hilfsköche.
Wir haben hier dieses Schweine...
Kursleiter Michael Hofmann ist
beeindruckt vom Wirken des Uganders.
... auf der Unterseite
kontrollieren.
Es ist ein sehr anspruchsvoller Job.
Er verwöhnt jene Leute, die in die-
sem guten Hotel die Gäste verwöhnen.
Sie kommen täglich zweimal zu Moses.
Er kann jeden Tag neu beweisen,
wie sein Feuer
für unseren Beruf ist.
Es ist der letzte Kurstag -
Prüfungstag.
Das Filet hat immer zwei Seiten.
Das ist die Seite der Haut,
und das ist die Aussenseite.
Diese Seite wollen wir
dem Gast präsentieren.
Zehn Kursteilnehmer, acht Nationen.
Schweizer sind hier
in der Minderheit.
Doch das bereitet Stefan Jung
keine Mühen.
Spannend. Schön. Verschiedene
Kulturen, verschiedene Nationen.
Da treffen viele aufeinander.
Es ist toll, mit solchen Leuten
zusammenzuarbeiten.
(Moses) ... heisses Wasser.
Die grosse Welt im Kleinen:
die Schweizer Küche, ein Modell für
eine friedlich funktionierende Welt?
Prüfungsexperte Marc Bachmann arbei-
tet seit 40 Jahren in dieser Branche.
Arbeitet man in der Gastronomie,
ist Multikulti immer ein Thema.
Als ich die Lehre machte, hatten wir
Italiener und Spanier in der Küche.
Wir haben gelernt,
Italienisch und Spanisch zu reden,
denn die wollten
nicht Deutsch lernen.
Ohne Ausländer würde die Gastronomie
nicht funktionieren.
Sicher hat es
schon Probleme gegeben.
Während der Balkankrise
musste man schauen,
was für Leute man im Team hatte.
Aber generell geht es sehr gut.
Alles gut?
- Ja.
Ilker Kivanc hat
eine bewegte Einwanderungsgeschichte:
der türkische Vater
ein Fussballprofi beim FC Zürich,
die portugiesische Mutter eine
Kürschnerin an der Bahnhofstrasse,
aufgewachsen
bei Schweizer Pflegeeltern.
Bei der Integration
ist das Wichtigste, dass die Leute,
die hierherkommen, die Chance haben,
Geld zu verdienen.
Neben der Integration ist Arbeit
wahrscheinlich das Allerwichtigste.
Dass sie beschäftigt sind,
eine Struktur haben.
Ein Einkommen, aber auch
dass sie ihre Liebsten -
ihre Kinder und Ehepartner -
bei sich haben können.
Das gibt alles sehr viel Energie
und sehr viel Flow.
Nur so können sie das Programm,
das sie hier erwartet,
moralisch ertragen.
* Beschwingte Musik, Surren *
Meine Damen und Herren,
die ersten Gäste sind da.
Es geht jetzt los.
* Beschwingte Musik *
Heinz Gerig reist nach Brüssel.
Das Schweizer Fernsehen berichtet.
Der Pionier in der Integration
von Flüchtlingen
ist vom Schweizer Botschafter
eingeladen worden.
Gerig soll europäischen Fachleuten
das von ihm aufgebaute RIESCO-
Integrationsmodell vorstellen.
Uns ist es wichtig, die richtigen
Kursteilnehmer auszuwählen.
Dafür gibt es gute Gründe.
Wir wollen von ihnen weder zu viel
noch zu wenig verlangen.
Wir wollen,
dass den Teilnehmern bewusst ist,
worauf sie sich da einlassen, bevor
sie sich für den Kurs verpflichten:
keine Ferien während dieses Jahres,
harte Arbeit,
Arbeit am Wochenende und am Abend.
Unglücklicherweise muss heute ein
Flüchtling Fähigkeiten vorweisen,
die 50 % höher liegen
als bei einem Schweizer,
nur schon um zu einem Bewerbungs-
gespräch eingeladen zu werden.
Es hat mich v.a. beeindruckt,
dass man sehr starken Wert
auf die Werte und das Verhalten
in der Schweiz -
also in der westlichen Welt - legt.
Ein sehr interessanter Punkt ist,
dass die Flüchtlinge
aufgrund ihrer Haltung ausgewählt
und darin auch trainiert werden.
Das ist ein Schlüssel zum Erfolg.
Dies war
eine sehr interessante Botschaft.
Ich hatte dies noch nie zuvor
so deutlich gehört.
Menschen, die in der Schweiz,
in der westlichen Welt arbeiten,
müssen die Werte
und Verhaltensweisen
kennenlernen und sie auch befolgen.
Das ist ein absolutes Muss.
Häufiger wird darauf
nicht so grossen Wert gelegt.
Wenn sich Mitglieder
unserer Business-Community
zur Integration von Migranten
äussern,
dann wird exakt dieser Punkt
angesprochen:
Okay, die Sprache ist ein Problem,
doch das ist lösbar.
Die beruflichen Fähigkeiten
sind ein Problem, doch lösbar.
Anders ist es mit der Haltung,
den Werten der Migranten.
Diese wissen nichts über die
Arbeitskultur in den Niederlanden.
Und genau in diesen Werten
werden die Flüchtlinge
in diesem Projekt unterrichtet.
Fachleute, etwas ratlos
ob der Millionen von Asylsuchenden,
die nach Europa gekommen sind.
Ein Integrationsmodell
aus der Schweiz liefert Erkenntnisse,
wie die soziale Eingliederung
dieser fremden Menschen
besser vonstatten gehen könnte.
Frühmorgens,
noch vor dem Stau der Pendler.
Erneut ist Heinz Gerig unterwegs
im Land, heute nach Effretikon.
Ein ganztägiger Besprechungsmarathon
steht auf dem Programm.
Im Kurszentrum des Baumeister-
verbandes Zürich/Schaffhausen
wird Entscheidendes verhandelt:
Es ist das Ende eines RIESCO-Kurses
im Baubereich,
und eine Maurerlehre
ist das Ziel der Anstrengungen.
Bauern würden vermutlich
von der Kirschenernte sprechen.
Heute kommt aus, wie es
in den Praktika gelaufen ist.
Reicht es für eine Lehrstelle?
Erhalten sie eine Lehrstelle?
Und dann versammeln sich Arbeitgeber,
Ausbildner und Flüchtlinge
im Halbstundentakt.
Zwei Monate
hat das Maurerpraktikum gedauert.
Zuvor waren die Flüchtlinge
von Berufsbildner Reto Steiner
81 Tage ins Maurerhandwerk
eingeführt worden.
Wie war das Praktikum?
Darf ich Ihnen das Wort übergeben.
Wie waren seine Leistungen?
Wie zufrieden waren Sie?
(Mann) Wir waren sehr zufrieden.
Er war auf einer
städtischen Baustelle in Zürich.
(Heinz Gerig)
Und wie war es für Sie?
(In gebrochenem Deutsch) Bisher
hatte ich keine Schwierigkeiten
bei der Arbeit,
ich kann mich nicht beschweren.
Ich bin mit allem zufrieden.
Wir haben ...
Wir haben das
an der Bauführersitzung besprochen,
also auch mit der Geschäftsleitung.
Wir würden ihm gerne
eine Praktikumslehrstelle anbieten.
(Heinz Gerig) Ich habe ein paar
wunderbare Rückmeldungen bekommen,
die ich Ihnen gerne geben möchte.
"Er war immer da
und hat nie gefehlt."
"Das persönliche Auftreten -
sehr gut. Er ist nett, man mag ihn."
Was die Sprachkenntnisse betrifft:
genügend bis gut.
Man kann sich mit Ihnen unterhalten,
aber es muss weiter
gefördert werden.
Wenn ich deine Noten anschaue,
auch jene der Schule ...
Die sind sicher noch
ein bisschen verbesserungsfähig.
Gratuliere! Super, sehr gut.
Wir haben ihn als sehr engagierten
Mitarbeiter kennengelernt.
Er wurde gut aufgenommen.
Er hat sich sehr eingesetzt.
Ich habe durchs Band
einen guten Eindruck gewonnen.
Das ist auch der Grund,
weshalb wir nun abklären,
ob wir ihn als Lehrling
einstellen können.
(Heinz Gerig) Sie haben es gehört.
Sie würden Ihnen gerne
eine Lehrstelle geben.
Wie ist das für Sie?
Ich habe im Tiefbau gearbeitet.
Ich habe auch
mit dem Belag gearbeitet.
Das gefällt mir.
- Ja.
Ich möchte auch
in einer Lehrstelle weitermachen.
(Heinz Gerig) Super, das ist toll.
"Kommt immer gepflegt, sehr gute
Motivation, immer pünktlich."
"Verhalten im Team sehr gut."
Genial.
Vielen Dank!
Alles Gute, bis später!
Deutschprüfung, oder? Toi, toi, toi!
Herr Metzler, vielen Dank! Merci.
Bis bald!
Wir hören voneinander.
Heinz Gerig erhält einen Telefonanruf
von seinem Sekretariat.
Ein Kursabsolvent
könne nicht zum Gespräch erscheinen,
Probleme mit der Polizei.
Es soll irgendein Problem
mit den Papieren geben.
Er ist von der Kripo
festgehalten worden.
Aber sie haben nicht gesagt,
worum es geht.
Das hatte ich schon zwei-, dreimal.
Sie haben keinen Ausweis dabei
und werden mitgenommen,
bis sie abgeklärt haben,
ob es jemand ist,
der zu Recht hier sein darf
oder nicht.
Ich glaube,
ich übergebe gleich Ihnen das Wort.
Erzählen Sie uns etwas
zu den Leistungen
und wie zufrieden Sie mit ihm sind.
Also ...
Wir haben ihn als sehr fleissigen
und interessierten jungen Menschen
kennen- und auch schätzen gelernt.
Und ...
Wir sind eigentlich überzeugt,
dass er
das handwerkliche Geschick hat,
um auch eine Maurerlehre
absolvieren zu können.
Woran wir noch zweifeln ist,
ob er schulisch ...
... ob er v.a. wirklich
genug gut Deutsch kann.
Ich denke v.a. ans Lesen.
Ich kann mich mit ihm
gut unterhalten.
Mit Händen und Füssen versteht er,
was ich eigentlich von ihm will.
Aber ich glaube, für die Schule ...
... reicht das noch nicht.
Der junge Eritreer ist enttäuscht,
dass er nicht gleich
die Maurerlehre beginnen kann,
dass er noch ein Jahr warten
und sich in der deutschen Sprache
verbessern soll.
Es gibt auch andere Personen im Kurs
mit dem gleichen Thema.
(Mann) Ich sagte ihm,
er müsse nicht nur Deutsch,
sondern auch Schweizerdeutsch
und Italienisch lernen.
Der Mensch kann vieles.
Sie können alles erreichen,
wenn Sie wollen.
Aber manchmal geht das
nicht auf dem kürzesten Weg.
Manchmal muss man
vielleicht einen Umweg machen.
Aber wichtig ist,
dass Sie das Ziel erreichen.
Es ist der richtige Weg.
- Ja.
Es ist ein sicherer Weg.
Meine Interpretation sieht so aus:
Für die Teilnehmer ist es
ein absoluter Gesichtsverlust,
gegenüber ihren Kollegen,
innerhalb ihrer Sippschaft.
Noch einmal ein Jahr warten?
Das ist ein No-Go, das geht nicht.
Obwohl es - wie du gesagt hast -
ein absoluter Gewinn wäre.
Ein einjähriges Praktikum absol-
vieren und die Schule besuchen -
das würde ihnen alles vereinfachen.
Sie sehen das vermutlich nicht so.
Darum ist es für sie
ein absolutes Versagen.
Und, ja ...
Wir hatten schon Leute, die deswegen
nicht an die Abschlussfeier kamen,
wegen kompletten Versagens.
"Das persönliche Auftreten ist sehr
gut, es gibt nichts zu bemängeln."
Und: "Wir stellen ihn an."
Das ist bereits passiert.
So geht es weiter,
einen ganzen Tag lang.
Und meist mit erfreulichen
Rückmeldungen der Baumeister.
Hier kann man leicht erkennen: Inte-
gration ist eine aufwendige Sache.
Und es gibt Leute, die finden diese
Bemühungen, diese Kosten, unnötig.
Wer von den Flüchtlingen genügend
motiviert und intelligent sei,
schaffe es auch so.
Bei den anderen sei der Aufwand
angesichts der kulturellen
Differenzen ohnehin vergebens.
Ich meine: "Das ist unmöglich."
Da kann einer
noch so motiviert sein -
wenn er die Baustelle betritt
und nicht weiss, was machen,
ist er am selben Tag
wieder zu Hause.
Sie müssen ihm jemanden
zur Seite stellen, der schaut,
dass er nicht in ein Loch fällt.
Da macht keiner mit.
Heute ist die Welt so:
Man muss eine Leistung erbringen,
um etwas zu erhalten.
Wenn man das nicht kann ...
Leistung erbringen kann man erst
mit dem richtigen Rüstzeug.
Darum glaube ich, dass es so
nicht funktionieren wird.
* Sanfte Flötentöne *
Es ist der letzte Tag
des RIESCO-Kurses.
Und es verspricht
ein wunderbarer Tag zu werden.
Zur Schlussfeier
sind Betreuerinnen und Bekannte
sowie Vertreter der Gastrobranche
geladen.
Ich begrüsse Sie
an der diesjährigen Abschlussfeier
des RIESCO-Lehrganges 2015
in Emmenbrücke.
Ich weiss, dass Sie in diesem Land
einen grossen Spagat machen müssen.
Mit einem Fuss
sind Sie in Ihrer Heimat,
mit dem anderen sind Sie hier.
Ich weiss nicht,
ob ich es genauso gut
hingekriegt hätte wie Sie,
wenn ich an Ihrer Stelle wäre.
Dieser Kurs hilft mir auf ...
... meinem Weg
zur Selbstständigkeit.
Und er macht mich
von der Sozialhilfe unabhängig.
(In gebrochenem Deutsch)
Ich bin auch sehr fröhlich,
weil Herr Gerig ...
Er ist unser ...
Er ist ein freundlicher Chef.
Er hat uns so viel geholfen.
Ich bin sehr froh über diesen Kurs.
Das war super für mich.
Ich wünsche Ihnen einen schönen Tag.
* Applaus *
Vielen Dank.
Frau Saba Zeray.
* Applaus *
Dafür haben sie ein Jahr lang
gekämpft und manchmal auch gelitten:
das RIESCO-Zertifikat, das den
Absolventen des Flüchtlingskurses
nun zu einem neuen Leben
verhelfen soll.
Alles Gute, danke!
So viel Motivation und so viel
Engagement wie von ihm ...
... habe ich noch nie gesehen.
Vier Jahre später.
Weggis am Vierwaldstättersee, der
Sitz von Hotel & Gastro formation,
der Ausbildungsorganisation der
Schweizer Hotel-und Gastrobranche,
seit 2005 Anbieterin
auch des RIESCO-Flüchtlingskurses.
Sind Sie der verantwortliche
Küchenchef? Dann bin ich richtig.
Ich bin auf der Suche
nach Praktikumsplätzen.
Ich habe 15 motivierte Flüchtlinge.
Sie würden jetzt gerne
ein Praktikum machen.
Doch, die können arbeiten!
Hier hängt sich Heinz Gerig
ans Telefon, zieht die Fäden,
um arbeitslose Flüchtlinge
in die Selbständigkeit zu führen.
Und mit welchem Erfolg?
Das Fazit vom RIESCO-Kurs 2015,
vier Jahre danach:
Neun der zwölf Absolventen
haben in den Arbeitsmarkt gefunden.
Das ist eigentlich
ein sehr schönes Resultat.
Ich weiss nicht,
warum die drei Personen
nicht im Arbeitsmarkt sind.
Ich weiss aber, dass sie die
Kompetenzen und Fähigkeiten hätten.
Die Gründe, warum sie nicht im Ar-
beitsmarkt sind, sind vielschichtig.
Aber ich meine: neun von zwölf -
das ist ein sehr schönes Resultat.
Heinz Gerig, ein Schweizermacher?
Das versuche ich gar nicht,
das ist nicht möglich.
Ich versuche, ihnen die Attribute
oder Verhaltensweisen mitzugeben,
damit sie es später einfacher haben.
Aber ich kann nicht aus einem ...
... Tibeter einen Schweizer machen.
Schweizer in diesem Sinn
werden sie nie.
Es stellt sich für mich
die andere Frage:
Müssen es Schweizer werden?
Ich habe eher das Gefühl: nein.
Es geht darum, sich hier
integrieren und leben zu können,
dass sie das Leben so meistern,
dass es ihnen dabei auch gut geht.
* Langgezogene Streicherklänge,
gemischt mit dumpfen Basstönen *
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Andrea Werlen - 2020